hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play louis's
this is gonna be the last part of this
game so when we get through this
excuse me rocks was I in your way as
soon as we get through this we're gonna
find the end of it no matter how long it
takes so I don't know how long it's
gonna take but we're wandering down a
dark hallway seems to be narrow and
filled with fear actually it's kind of
reminds me of the ending of um
ooh can I move this yes I can okay
what's inside nothing do I jump in okay
probably not okay so it reminds me of
the ending of amnesia Dark Descent
because oh no boo boo boo bones because
remember when you were going down that
hallway towards the end there were the
two rooms off to the side it's kind of
thematically similar but I'm not sure if
it's like a direct correlation I'm just
saying it looks similar hello am I
supposed to be finding something down
here I apologize my voice is a little
hoarse cuz I was screaming a lot
yesterday you'll find out why later but
I was just screaming my head off and my
voice is really ragged right now
okay more boo boo boo bones um am I am I
still looking for the blacksmith do i oh
that was a ladder I thought he saw
something down there need I ask again
where's the blacksmith what he found the
blacksmith forever ago oh look I got a
stick ray good for me I got a staff what
do with the staff let's see a brick wall
over there do I've asked the brick wall
down with my staff mmm baby hello cabe's
hmm these tum seems a little loose let's
poke it with a stick
ha ha how did that happen what to take
yeah yeah I'm so strong we put out that
brick wall he he knocks you down with a
stick
we're two blocks mad okay it's a lot of
bones I'm wondering why they were doing
so many human sacrifices mmm oh man
oh I need to run ha ha ha this is very
similar to amnesia I remember this very
much so talk about an obstacle that I do
beep epically over is it still behind me
uh-oh run no no it's gonna get me I
shouldn't have turned around epic bleep
epic I'm amazing jump over the water
oh not water not water
Oh what about okay flashbacks to early
amnesia playthroughs uh many a plenty
job epic yumping jumping across Jane Oh
what done
oh nice moves Brougham I couldn't have
done that myself I could have crouched I
could have done it okay so I'm in some
sort of cave with some lovely wall
formations here I mean I'm if there's
one thing that I gotta say about this
game it's not scary but it definitely
looks nice like a lot of work has been
put into the game I got to admit it's
it's very very well done so anyway we're
down here now is that a lantern wait I
already have a lantern nevermind why am
I worried about that it had a pile of
books
it's a row ah ha ha what you think there
are actually people down here why didn't
you get the robes off the guy that you
knocked out that was my previous
suggestion why they just cannot notice
hey who's the new guy there was only
like three of us but okay you can join
us anyway it's fine whatever
logic logic okay actually I don't know
how many of them down here so there may
be like 10 and then they be like who's
the new guy oh there's so many of us
what area we're just getting new members
all over the place
one two three four oh no oh no here is
the catalyst I see that you were ready
for the ceremony
hi you look surprised yep I guess you
don't have a clue about what's going on
No
okie dokie are one of us just as your
father and your mother were okay since
you were born you were meant to be the
vessel for the ellipsis of the great
Stipe FOIAs leftist huh he made sure
that you and your mother would remain
hidden mmm it took us years to track her
down when we did we only had to wait for
the right time
mmm that time came when she wrote the
letter asking you to visit her then we
led you here and tested you you passed
our tests and proved that you really are
the chosen one
I know it is enter the pigs yes ma'am
metal feel the great power of toy boy is
burning through your every cell you will
become a god yeah reality will be yours
so don't hesitate power and redeem this
world yeah yeah yeah I was your black
persevere in this pit wait was this I'm
to make a decision decision made whoa at
first there was darkness and silence
then I felt a levitating sensation like
I was pulled toward ya godlike powers
white light filling me with warmth ha
celebrated towards it I felt my human
existence melting away
at the same time a new kind of awareness
was born inside me I knew that my own
body could not handle that power
I didn't care anymore a new existence
had risen filled with power beyond
imagination
yeah to shape the world according to my
own will yeah yeah yeah best learning
ever I turn into a god yeah yeah who
wouldn't make that decision yeah
zap take all this you ladies job take
all this you stupid bro bid people zap
ha ha
take this you stupid town yep oh is that
a wolf zap ha ha ha ha I'm mad with
power
Wow no man with the torch can stop me
zap oh why did it was to make that
decision
zap all little people hiding in the
house where's the blacksmith now is that
there's a blacksmith there's a
blacksmith's making blacksmiths through
the place yeah best ending ever
oh that was extra fun I mean like I said
before it wasn't exactly scary I mean it
probably it was more atmospheric ly
inclined but I don't know I just I'm
probably pretty numb to a lot of these
things so this game wasn't scary for me
but in you know it might it was dark and
atmospheric and very closed in so it it
had a lot of potential there to be good
but you know I mean it was still good
don't get me wrong still good it's like
an old-school adventure style game you
know the point-and-click style stuff
except in a 3d world he was really cool
anyway oh it's this
okay alright so that was something I'm
not sure what that was it was like a
dark coil opening up I'm actually gonna
see if I can continue and choose the
other choice so that you guys can see
what the other ending is hello I will
not take godlike amazing powers cuz that
would just be too awesome
I shall instead ask where the blacksmith
is am I supposed to use this on
something lady lady you want to see my
staff all my staff is gone well what do
I do
how do I not make this choice
how do I ghost how do I say no they tell
me just say what oh yeah I threw it in
the pit ha ha suck on that what have you
done what have you done no I have to get
out hot through this other door over
here Oh My yes perfect how perfect for
my escape get up there God there thank
you
OOP OOP yeah it's always no what have
you done I wouldn't turn down godlike
powers ah hello Ronnie Oh
please save me oh well that cave always
there I bet this pops out right behind
my car collapse I realized that my life
had me please my birth I had been chosen
to be the one that would hold the power
to either change or preserve the world
as we know it
I saw and experienced things that up
until now I believed only existed in
fiction uh I know now that there are
forces lurking hidden in our reality
that we are unaware of as we are
occupied by our daily life uh-huh
these forces are constantly trying to
enter our world it's up to us whether to
let them in or not
ooh red eyes all right so that's the end
um uh I mean as opposed to having
godlike powers and be able to zap anyone
you want zap zap zap I would rather
choose the godlike powers but if you
want to see you want to see the other
ending you have it there and you can see
it so anyway I thought it was a great
game um it wasn't scary but that doesn't
mean it's bad it was still a good game
well put-together worked well um some of
the logic was a little wonky so it's not
perfect but for an indie game made by a
small team of people and the voice
acting was good and the graphics were
amazing and everything else worked
together I still think it was a good
game so everyone should probably give it
a try links in the description if you
want to give it a go they're probably
going to be some more sequels to it I
don't know there was some kind of
hinting at a dark portal opening up so
anyway thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation with more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video bye
Jenna
Oh
you